sometimes you have to get a little
creative to stand out on Twitch whether
it's the way you dress the way you act
or by adding a bit of extra production
to your stream
[Music]
and when it comes to gaming being
absolutely cracked isn't always enough
to make it big so it's no surprise that
one of the platform's most successful
streamers didn't blow up just because of
his gameplay instead he's known for his
back flips
let's go
meet valorence most active content
creator Joseph Keo Winkler he built an
entire brand by bouncing around on
stream all while fragging out in every
game he plays
let's go
pick me up
let's go Keo is valorin's supreme
speedrunner who after years of competing
in various titles has cemented himself
as one of the most athletic entertainers
you'll ever see on Twitch but how did he
go from streaming OverWatch to just a
handful of viewers to building the
world's first trampoline streaming
Studio how did he land a spot on one of
esports's most storied orgs and how is
he using his own experience to help his
friends grow their content
hi Molly bomb Oh I'm running away
[Music]
we're good for backup
okay wait
they didn't stick let's go
we actually did it
all right so before he became the king
of backflips on Twitch where exactly did
this 24 year old Valerian speedrunner
get his start well Keo was born and
raised in Orange County California where
he was homeschooled up until High School
growing up his brother introduced him to
video games and they competed against
each other in games like Smash Bros and
Mario Kart but unlike most Gamers Keo
actually enjoyed touching grass or at
the very least touching water as a
springboard diver I liked watching
diving on the Olympics and then I my
brother had left swimming to go to water
pool and that was just not really the
sport for me and I was still swimming
and I was like I don't really want to do
this anymore if my brother's not here so
uh I'm gonna try diving and then I went
to a class later that day and then ended
up diving for 10 years and winning three
national championships and that was kind
of my whole sport near the end of his
diving career Keo got into OverWatch
thanks again to his brother but because
of his potato PC he only played
projectile based DPS Heroes like pharah
and Hanzo because their attacks required
more time to travel Keo enjoyed
OverWatch so much that he set a goal for
himself if he could hit GM on his crappy
PC he would Fork up the cash to buy a
new one so that he could stream and so
it took me a year of like really
grinding and getting better and stuff
but I finally hit uh Grandmaster put a
bunch of money into his streaming PC and
then started streaming from there now
since was only
only a handful of people when he first
started out on Twitch he wanted to think
of a way to make his content stand out
he knew that being good at OverWatch
wasn't gonna be enough to bring new eyes
to his stream there were already plenty
of big names in that scene and what he
came up with was
let's say
unique being at three to ten viewers
I was like Hey how do I set myself apart
from all these other streamers you know
I mean I can get a webcam I can put cool
graphics on but at the end of the day
I'm no different than everybody else
playing OverWatch in the same category
as me so uh I was one of the highest
ranks in the game that was already like
a really cool thing that I could you
know pitch to people basically but I
thought okay if somebody Scrolls down
all the way in the twitch directory
what can I do to make them click on my
stream versus everyone else around me
right now and so what I did for the
first 2 000 followers on Twitch is I did
a backflip for every single follow that
I got and I would put that directly in
my title so that if somebody did scroll
down they'd be like one follow equals
one backflip but I I don't believe it
they click on it they follow me I
actually do a backup they're like holy
crap
let's go
so yes Keo did a backflip for each and
every follow for his first 2 000
followers not long after he was awarded
entry to twitch's new affiliate program
and he began bat flipping for every new
subscriber but around that same time he
also entered his freshman year of
college at Cal Poly San Luis Obispo as a
computer science major while juggling
school and streaming Kyo got on the
fortnite bandwagon and he got absolutely
cracked at the game soon he was
competing in events taking down some of
the game's best players and of course
hitting some crispy backflips
try hard
let's go
pick me up
let's go and as more people tuned into
Keo stream School became a lesson less
enjoyable and he had to have a very
difficult conversation with his parents
I came home for summer and I talked to
my parents and just said hey
I want to try streaming full-time I
think that I can do it and I don't want
to get an internship this summer are you
guys like okay with that pretty much and
uh they didn't really know too much
about streaming but they trusted me and
they saw how much I didn't enjoy college
and they were like yeah I mean if this
is the path you need to take then that's
great and they're super supportive Keo
took a massive risk that summer but soon
it paid off because around the same time
TSM was making changes to their fortnite
roster so in an effort to join forces
with Daequan Keo decided to Showcase his
skills on the fortnite subreddit and his
post blew up
thank you
that video put Keo on the fortnite map
and as more and more people discovered
his very public TSM audition a
completely different organization came
knocking I got approached by Cloud9
after submitting this pretty public like
debut of hey this is all my skill I got
this out here and uh so Cloud9 reached
out to me and said hey do you want to be
the fourth for our roster and I actually
hit them back up and said no I would
rather be a content creator but I'll
totally compete for you guys at the same
time as a member of
grow and he was doing pretty well
competing in various events alongside
his teammates he even managed to take
home fifteen thousand dollars at
twitchcon 2019 But as time went on and
fortnite morphed into a completely
different game Keo like many others grew
frustrated with all the changes so he
gave other games like Apex and even CS
go a try eventually he landed on
twitch's latest craze valorant he became
the platform's resident killjoymane
before launching a series that pushed
his content out to an even larger
audience on YouTube he decided to become
a valorant speedrunner with the release
of sky was thinking okay I have a really
good opportunity to like look at this
agent and try to come up with a Content
series around this agent since I have
like a little bit a couple days in
advance to think about it uh I just
spent some time like researching other
people's content and then looking at
other things and just decided okay I'm
gonna try the sky Speed Run and if
you're wondering how in the hell
someone's speed runs valorent well Keo
decided that in order to play each new
agent on his main radiant ranked account
he would first have to hit Immortal rank
with them on a fresh account keo's agent
speed runs allowed him to crack
valorence YouTube algorithm and even
share some of his Newfound knowledge
with his fellow creators between helping
his friends learn the ins and outs of
streaming Keo continued putting out
speed runs each time a new agent came
out eventually Keo grew too big to do
backflips for every sub because
Odyssey there were just so many of them
that it probably would have killed him
instead he started doing one backflip
for every competitive match he won or
sometimes for every kill he got but
throughout all of the backflips streams
and speed runs Keo secretly planning
something behind the scenes last year at
the end of last year I moved in with
grim and Shiro and revealed that I built
the world First Trampoline streaming
studio and with that announcement again
nobody knew I bought a house nobody knew
grimaturo for moving in nobody knew I
put a trampoline in that house so that
was really fun to like it was a bit
stressful keeping that secret for almost
a year but uh
I basically announced all of those
things at once and then started a
uncapped subathon and did it for 27 days
and
uh yeah I ended up amassing
20 000 subscribers across those 27 days
I got a dog as a result of that I got a
tattoo I have a bunch of sub goals that
I'm still actually finishing now yeah I
feel like I just it was very complete
and I'm just I'm really happy with how
everything went it was awesome
hi Molly bomb Oh I'm running away
[Music]
okay wait
they didn't stick it let's go
we actually did it
um
trampoline bakkies
yeah okay
and now
all right
let's go
balloons that's how it works dude ah
four three wait wait see if it actually
hits it
zero mileage
Keo sabathon put him up there with some
pretty big names as one of only 157
twitch streamers to ever break twenty
thousand subscribers and now that he's
built such a strong Foundation Keo wants
to focus on putting out the best content
imaginable no matter where his fans are
watching him he always even set to
appear on America
year you
he's from backflipping for follows in
his bedroom to buying his first house
and even building an entire Studio to
keep his dream alive and with more Valor
and agents on the way we'll likely see a
lot more of him it's time to kind of
learn a new skill set and then be able
to produce the content on Twitch so that
when people do show up to a stream it's
gonna be like a really awesome stream
for everybody so
um you know consistently grow on the
YouTube try to get up to the half a
million and the 1 million subscriber
Mark is kind of the the next big goal
because a springboard diver oh like a
diver like like I was like what the
is a springboard diver
so like a diver like you just zoom and
dive that makes sense
yeah circles and flips and